I have to do passcodes on my passcodes
on my iPad because I have all this like
stuff on it um all this like stuff on it
yeah you got real dodgy when you look
around called olders for youngers
website baby olders for young whether
you're an older or a younger or maybe 10
days Felix on earth know about that I
feel like he should know yeah it is
honest I have this weird porn obsession
of course of older men and younger women
okay about nine year old decrepid like
on the verge of death okay that's super
super gross yeah and kind of a bummer
yeah but this is this is the slippery
slope you go down with pornography right
right yeah I talked about this once
where it's like hey you know I thought
that like fetish used to mean like
fishnet pantyhose right that's better
not at all it's just people pooping into
hats and then someone has to wear that
hat and the whole thing yeah yeah the
the suggestions that come up on websites
are weird yeah but you think really
really bugs me a lot those guys who look
like Stanley oh yeah Stanley in any of
them and the other are like so Stan from
[Music]
professional okay yeah what you're
talking about is crimes
I mean it's I know your course what it
is and here's what it is and I'm gonna
just say so every everyone whether
you're a family so I'm gonna explain to
everyone right now listening okay yeah I
don't want people that let it get out of
control what it is I'm not into mm-hmm
when I see the old men I see me because
I feel like I'm old and I feel like I'm
not sexy and so when I see you know mean
older dude I don't think this got better
than actually it was one of these
horrible things where it was kind of
vague and then it got more specific and
it actually got way
yeah so you're saying there's no proper
Asian representation in American porn
see that's another thing it's like
there's net have you ever seen an
American porn and seen some Asian doing
you know me no no you're right yeah
Chuck noodle you know chopped noodles
not in it porn star yeah Frank dumpling
is not in it if Frank dumpling was
rolling up doesn't mean it's a fat
Chinese guy yeah
with just hope some regular girl I would
I would download and that would be I
could support your agency yeah like all
sukira right it's always she's always
with some dude that looks like you know
Hey yeah Josh Brolin I got a real
question for you Bobby
it feels like you're really focusing on
the dudes a lot I mean I don't I don't
want it to peel this onion like well
she's fine but why doesn't this guy look
like San Li why is this guy not a Korean
Stan Lee who's about to die with an
oxygen tube otherwise so yeah you're
right you know I feel like I name in why
what does no matter yeah it does it
doesn't because if you if there's a
penis in the scene uh-huh right yeah and
people are doing things to the penis
right I can't ignore the fact that there
is penile in it mhm
and so you know it's like um you put
yourself in that man's you know he's
basically playing yourself okay you know
talking yeah it's not like I want to
suck it okay why it's more like that's
me I know I understand its fulfillment
right yeah no it's not so you don't go
to POV stuff because you've got to see
the weird old gentleman yeah I can't do
POV you like well why that face towards
[Music]
nobody I don't like the angles of it
Yeah right like you know I saw one POV
what you just see a girl's bellybutton
and her mouth uh-huh you can see the
hole you can't see the hole Stanley Lisa
mattresses
[Music]